Asalam
alaikum. How are you guys doing?
Everyone is seeing what's happening now
in Palestine where these backwards
barbarians, yeah, these horrible people
that have no integrity and no honor
whatsoever, have started blasting again
the women and children. It's a war
against children really. That's what
this is. And to be honest with you,
we're we're tired of this now. We're
really very tired of all of this. Like
we're fed up, you know, of of this. But
there's something we can do about it.
And this is the only thing that I can
see that right now everyone here can do
about it which is give a zakat. Actually
give not just the saddaka. Yeah sodaka
should go without saying now we have to
give sodaka and we have to try our best
but give zakat as well to the people of
Palestine. I know you're probably
thinking of where to give the zakat.
This is just a quick link. Press it now.
It will take a couple of minutes and it
will make us feel like we're doing
something in the situation in Palestine
because this is otherwise a hopeless
situation. token.